Russia is invading Europe in 2014 this
is a big deal the Russian military now
being directly involved in fighting
Ukrainian government forces satellite
imagery show Russian combat units combat
units southeast of Donetsk in eastern
Ukraine so President Obama Western
leaders everybody is furious about this
Russia has deliberately and repeatedly
violated the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of Ukraine to understand why
this is all happening in Ukraine you
actually have to go back to 2012 which
is when Russian President Vladimir Putin
ran for re-election there were big
protests in Moscow st. Petersburg in a
couple other places he completely
panicked and that's when he shifted
political strategies from economic
growth to anti Western paranoia
conservative Christian orthodoxy and a
Russian Imperial revival nationalism
then jump ahead to November 2013 that's
when the Ukraine crisis breaks out you
have protesters in Kiev that went to
topple the pro-russian government
replace it with a pro-european and Putin
sees this is a direct threat fermented
by the Americans against Russia when the
government Falls that's when he invades
to annex Crimea he gains a huge
popularity boost in Russia over this it
works out for him wonderfully
politically and he gets addicted to it
and that's why shortly after that he
starts supporting these pro-russia
separatists rebels in eastern Ukraine
the rebels take over publicity's Putin
starts escalating and July he hands the
rebels these very sophisticated
surface-to-air missiles which they used
to shoot down Malaysian Airlines flight
17 the US officials say pro-russian
rebels are responsible for crane is fed
up the West is fed up Ukrainian military
moves in to retake these eastern cities
actually push out a number of the rebels
Putin really panics because he thinks
he's going to lose everything and has
prepared this huge cost of economic
sanctions for doing it he couldn't
afford to build up the crisis it's so
crucial for Russia and then just kind of
watch these rebels lose so he was pulled
into an invasion that clearly is not
going to work out in his long-term
strategic
the thing that makes that so scary is
that if that's the case that means he
has no strategy it means he has no
actual objective that he's trying to
achieve and it means that there is no
clear end in sight for this crisis